hi everyone Sal KH here from Khan
Academy and I'm here to ask if you're in
a position to do so to seriously think
about supporting Khan Academy and its
mission of free worldclass education for
anyone anywhere as you can imagine that
is a very big mission statement and we
are serious about it many of y'all have
already benefited from KH Academy or
know folks who do there's over 150
million registered users were in 50
languages all over the world and growing
there's been 50 plus efficacy studies
showing that a students are even able to
put in 30 to 60 Minutes a week on KH
Academy nearly every one of those
studies point to 20 30 40 50%
acceleration more than expected so we're
serious about covering all of the core
academic subjects from prek through the
core of college and making it as
accessible to anyone anywhere as free as
possible but you can imagine even though
we are giving this away it is not free
to produce Khan Academy is much more
than me now we're over 250 folks just in
the home office and we have hundreds and
thousands of people outside uh through
the world who are also helping to
forward our mission and our budget and I
get a little anxiety every time I say it
is around $70 million a year and now I
say that's a real number and that's what
it creates anxiety because myself and
our team we we have to go out there and
raise that every year but I remind
people about the social return on
investment there that's the budget of a
large High School in a country like the
United States but we are reaching a
reasonable percentage of humanity and
have the potential over the decades to
come of reaching a large chunk of
humanity I'm hoping that over the next
decades or or or Generations that
billions upon billions are able to
leverage these tools and be able to
access their potential and and and truly
get an education and and become part of
um have a vibrant life and and be a
member member of society but we would
not be able to do this and especially
would not be able to give it away for
free if not for support from folks like
yourself and there is some good news
here every dollar you donate will be
matched and it's really important to
think about it at this time of year when
people are thinking about giving because
this is really the support that allows
us to invest throughout the year to
continue to support the tens and
hundreds of millions of folks who are
already using Khan Academy and to grow
that and to add content and to add
features and as you all know there's a
whole new world going on with artificial
intelligence and we want to make sure
that that type of powerful technology is
being used for good and it's being used
to empower people in the most accessible
way possible and we would not be able to
do that without your support so thank
you for listening I hope you seriously
think about making a donation I will be
very grateful our team will be very
grateful but even more important you
should think about the tens of millions
of Learners of all ages that will be
empowered because of your very generous
Act